four people earn a hundred and eighty
dollars for working in an after-school
program if they divide this money up
equally how much will each person
receive so we want to divide
180 dollars into four equal groups so
that each of the four people can have
the same amount so we want to divide 180
we want to divide 180 by four
by four we want to take 180 divided by
4. now most of us don't know this off
the top of our heads so we need to solve
for we need to do a little bit of
division so another way of writing this
exact same expression is to write 4
divided into
divided into
180 when you write it like this it's
easier to do it if either of them
actually has more than one digits
especially if the number we're dividing
into has more than one or two or three
or four digits so let's do it
so the first thing you say is well does
four go into one well no four does not
go into one it's larger than one so you
could put a zero up here but instead of
doing that let's just say let's just
move on to the right and say well okay
it doesn't go into one does four go into
eighteen
well four times 4 is 16 so that goes
into 18 at least 4 times 4 times 5 let
me write this down
4 times 4 is equal to 16 so that goes
into 18
4 times 5 is equal to 20. so that does
not go into 18. so this is going to go
into 18 four times 4 times 4 is 16
and now we subtract we essentially find
the remainder here 18 minus 6 is 2
now we want to bring down this 0 because
we really said 4 goes into 180 40 times
because it's in the tens place 40 times
4 is 160 180 minus 160 is 20. that's why
we bring down the zero but if you just
think about the process you say okay
what's the large what's the smallest if
i just go with the one four doesn't go
into it so let me move on so let me look
at the one and the eight eighteen four
goes into that four times
four times four is 16 subtract from 18
you get a 2 bring down the 0. now 4 goes
into 20 how many times well we just
wrote it over here 4 times 5 is equal to
20. 4 times 5 is equal to 20. so 4 goes
into 20
5 times five times four is 20 you
subtract and you have no remainder left
over so 180 divided by four is equal to
45. so if these four people were to
split the money
equally they'll each get forty five
dollars